federal investigators say they forced
Tessa out of a probe of a deadly crash
in California a driver using the
electric car makers autopilot system
died after crashing into a highway
barrier last month the NTSB said
yesterday that tesla released
information about the investigation
before it was confirmed and that's a big
no-no they say but in a statement Tesla
says it withdrew from the panel adding
we believe in transparency so an
agreement that prevents public release
of information for over a year is
unacceptable we we experienced the
autopilot system the Tesla Model 3 this
week by we I mean me and CEO Elon Musk
we asked him about the safety concerns
you've got this you know beautiful like
glass roof put a lot of evidence against
the roof so that it's got infrared
coatings and ultraviolet coatings
effectively it's like a really good pair
of sunglasses
Tesla models three stands out for its
sleek minimalistic design but it's one
of the automakers key features this is
so creeping me health out so you're not
turning the car is turning that's
getting renewed attention the autopilot
system the function aids driving tasks
like staying within a lane but it is not
supposed to replace a human driver we
can't expect people you see how it's
like warning us yeah what did they want
you to do that because plant my hands
are on the wheel well what's the purpose
of having autopilot if you still have to
put your hands on the wheel Yvan oh it
because the probability of an accident
with autopilot is just last less likely
but not impossible
federal investigators are looking into
last month's deadly crash in California
involving a Model X operating an
autopilot mode was there a defect with
the system the system worked as
described which is that it's a hands-on
system it is not a self-driving system a
week after the accident Tesla announced
that the driver had received several
visual and one audible hands-on warning
earlier in the drive and the drivers
hands were not detected on the wheel for
six seconds prior to the collision
releasing that information drew
criticism from federal officials doing
their own investigation you do know that
you ticked off the National
Transportation Safety Board by releasing
the results before the investigate
was completed why did you do that well
it's actually we've always released the
autopilot now yes I wrote a pilot the
NTSB takes they take a long time to
complete an investigation they'll take
over a year so as I look weak you know
can't wait for a year to release
information that's way too long too long
especially for a company under such
intense public scrutiny but it's
important emphasize it will never be
perfect
autopilot will never be perfect no I
mean nothing in the real world is
perfect but I do think that long term it
can reduce accidents by a factor of 10
so there are 10 fewer fatalities and
tragedies and serious injuries and
that's a really huge difference
I'm telling I gotta get used to the
autopilot Elon Musk is a very good
driver although he did cruise through a
couple of stop signs but he's a very
very good driver he said it is good it's
good Gale it's good the price of the car
is 35,000 bare-bones to fifty fifty
thousand fully loaded and I asked him of
course he drives the test I said did you
get a discount nobody gets a discount
and Cooling him he pays full price no
family no friends everybody has to pay
full price for the car
playing a run yeah it's just hard to get
his hands back on there's at one point
he had is yes it was making me very
nervous and he's very he goes no I got
this it's all good so I need a little
more training with that yeah that made
me a little nervous it's very it's a
very very cool looking car and very
timely interview yes thanks yeah thanks
oh you're welcome